bis es dann eines morgens an der tür
klingelte die postbotin also ich hab dir
eingelassen die ist aber nicht
reingekommen sondern hat mir sofort
sondern brief irgendwie im briefkasten
geschmissen und ist weg gelöst und ich
dachte mir so du kleine warte doch zehn
sekunden die wahrheit zu faul das paket
nach oben zu bringen so das ist ja
irgendwie manchmal so eheleute was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen bei einmal
ein video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's gut ja viele von euch haben
wahrscheinlich mein video von gestern
gesehen holt auch einmal kurz dieses
handy gezeigt habe aus china oder wo es
herkommt
darum geht es auch heute unter anderem
und zwar habe ich vor ungefähr zwei
wochen das video rausgehauen wo ich euch
das handy gezeigt habe was ich über mich
damals bestellt habe und ich hatte ja
schon mal gesagt dass es nicht wirklich
das handy war was ich bestellt hat
sondern irgendwie ein anderes und jetzt
im endeffekt habe ich halt zwei handys
also mal eben die kurzfassung ich habe
vor ungefähr einem monat ein handy
bestellt halten billiges henry für 31
euro wollte das essen das ganze jahr
über wird wie in letzter zeit öfter mal
und man kann dann eigentlich immer auf
der seite verfolgen wann das handy
ankommt und zu anfangs standard jo das
handy kommt bis zum 19
dritter also durch das nicht jedes handy
co bis zum 19 briten sondern kommt bis
zum 19
und ich hab dann halt gedacht ja cool da
kann ich das video ja bald schon machen
das ist ja gar nicht mehr so lange
und dann war auch der neunzehnte dritter
das handy war allerdings nicht da ich
kann euch mal hier kurz ein foto ein
werden das ist jetzt von einem anderen
produkt von nach hause die ich bestellt
habe in dem letzten video das steht hier
kommt bis zum 15
die genauen daten weiß ich jetzt
natürlich nicht mehr aus dem kopf kann
auch sein das ist der 17 der dritte war
kein plan
auf jeden fall schon mal abends von dem
tag muss eigentlich ankommen sollte das
ist am nächsten tag ankommt oder am
übernächsten tag und am 21
glaube ich oder mit 22 toten keine
ahnung habe ich dann das handy beim zoll
abgeholt das haben ja auch viele von
euch schon vermutet all das kommt nicht
an weil es beim zoll liegt ist ja auch
logisch irgendwie oder kann ja logisch
sein weil wohl ab 30 euro alles beim
zoll liegen bleibt was so aus dem
asiatischen raum kommen oder generell
aus dem ausland ich habe dann also eine
mail bekommen und sollte das handy beim
zoll ab wohl mit bestellbestätigung usw
das davor gezeigt und habe dann auch
irgend ein paket in die hand bekommen
war ja auch ein handy drin ihr
vielleicht ein kurzer ausschnitt so soll
das erste handy aus was ich bekommen
habe
also leute sieht aus wie ein handy von
senioren würde ich mal sagen könnte auch
mein opa haben es geht wahrscheinlich
nicht an
doch es geht an ich film einfach mal ein
bisschen mit meinem iphone also das
hochfahren geht jetzt nicht so schnell
übrigens man sieht mich da voll in der
spiegelung es geht ja so sieht das aus
während des videos ist mir schon
aufgefallen dass das überhaupt nicht das
handy ist was ich bestellt habe es war
zwar kein gutes handy aber es war nicht
das was ich bestellt habe an sich hat
sich ja von anfang an um dieses handy
gehandelt call rio 5.0 für 31 euro in
gold eigentlich genau dieses handy habe
ich bestellt und das handy was ich dann
am anfang hatte sei halt anders aus das
war irgendwie sondern alt kartell oder
alcatel ich weiß nicht ich kenne die
marke nicht die war wohl früher sehr
bekannt keine ahnung ich habe das dann
auch mal google und das handy was ich
eigentlich bekommen hat war sogar teurer
als das hat irgendwie 60 70 euro kostet
oder so im internet was mir von anfang
an gewundert hat die haben wir halt
einfach ein handy in die hand gedrückt
ohne halt dass er jetzt meine adresse
drauf steht aber ich hab halt gedacht
die haben das halt vorher ausgepackt um
halt zu sehen ob da irgendetwas drin ist
was im wert von über 30 euro hat keine
ahnung ich kenne mich da echt nicht aus
ihr könnt mich da gerne in den
kommentaren aufklären oder vielleicht
eure vermutung in die kommentare
schreiben
der nächste punkt der mich dann aber
weiterhin verwundert hat was ich gerade
noch vergessen habe zu sagen ich konnte
irgendwie am ende ich glaub so kurz
bevor ich das halt meinem zoll abgeholt
habe hier noch bayerisch anklicken ob
ich das paket erhalten habe oder nicht
und ich habe jeden tag immer nein
angeklickt oder immer wenn das neu kam
aber irgendwie war das so keine ahnung
da habe ich auch dann keine meldung zu
bekommen ob das jetzt ob ich mein geld
wieder kriege oder sonst was
das habe ich vergessen zu sagen auf
jeden fall konnte ich das dann auch
nachdem ich das handy noch habe stand
hier das ist mein paket noch nicht
angekommen ist und ich konnte die ganze
zeit noch auf nein klicken und ich
dachte anhalt sehr gut es ist
wahrscheinlich ein fehler oder so
ignoriert die jetzt du hast dein handy
bekommen
du hast das bezahlt das war zwar ein
anderes handy aber was willst du machen
ich wollte mich da jetzt auch nicht um
diese 40 euro die ich dafür bezahlt hat
irgendwie beschweren und also ich meine
an sich hatte ich ein handy was dann
sogar einen höheren wert hatte bis es
dann eines morgens an der tür klingelte
die postbotin also ich hab dir
eingelassen die ist aber nicht
reingekommen sondern hat mir sofort
seinen brief irgendwie im briefkasten
geschmissen und ist weg gelöst und ich
dachte mir so du kleine warte doch zehn
sekunden die wahrheit zu frau das paket
nach oben zu bringen so das ist hier
irgendjemand
und ich muss dann halt am nächsten tag
abholen habe ich auch gemacht jetzt soll
im video habe ich euch das ja schon
gezeigt und ich dachte mir so als das
paket in der hand hatte kommt aus china
was da jetzt wohl drin ist als ich war
wirklich sehr gespannt so ich hab's
aufgemacht und mit drei wochen
verspätung oder zweieinhalbwöchiger
verspätung war das handy da ich habe die
verpackung schon den müll geworfen ich
guck mal kurz ob ich noch finde weil der
stand drauf irgendwie dass es halt auch
beim zoll lag aber dann irgendwie weiter
geschickt wurde warum auch immer kleinen
moment so die verpackung habe ich leider
schon weggeworfen ich habe es jetzt gar
nicht gefunden aber das ist auch nicht
so schlimm
also das war wirklich da drin und das
lag wurden halt auch beim zoll wurde mir
dann aber geschickt mit voll verspätung
ja und ich saß da halt so und habe mir
gedacht was machst du jetzt du hast ja
an sich irgendwie ein handy geschenkt
bekommen muss ich das jetzt zurückgeben
ist an sich überhaupt nicht meine schuld
deswegen juckt ziemlich im endeffekt
auch nicht ihr könnt gerne meine
kommentare schreiben was man in solcher
situation jetzt machen sollte sollte man
einfach gar nichts sagen oder keine
ahnung ich hatte so was goldoni also wie
gesagt ein handy bestellt zwei bekommen
ja das war so die story dahinter die
viele von euch auch gerne mal hören
wollten habt ihr oft gestern kommentiert
und was ich auch noch machen sollte hier
das wir jetzt war nämlich das video das
handy das handy jetzt mal auspacken und
mal schauen was das so kann gleiches
prinzip eigentlich wie letztes mal ich
habe jetzt einfach nur das angeht was da
alles balls und mehr kann ich mir auch
schenken also wir haben ja einmal das
handy wirklich in gold geht gar nicht
mal so schlecht aus kamera frontkämpfer
erinnert ein bisschen an so ein samsung
dazu haben wir ein usb kabel adapter und
kopfhörer und noch eine mini
bedienungsanleitung auf englisch und
chinesisch so ich zieh mal kurz die
folie ab und mal gucken ob das so angeht
ich glaube nicht ich lass das mal kurz
auf und dann melde ich mich wieder
bis gleich leute schaut mal hier ist
einfach der anschluss zum laden
obendrauf auch noch nie gesehen oder hey
guck mal das ist einfach oben
heute schaut euch das an das soll der
adapter sein
der passt aber gar nicht unsere
steckdosen hier sowohl was man
vielleicht was war nicht nicht dass ich
da jetzt einen stromschlag kriege oder
so wird man hier das hat einfach gar
nichts mit einem normalen stecker zu tun
passt doch überhaupt nicht rein aber gut
so jetzt muss ich das aber irgendwie an
kriegen leute ich glaube wir haben ein
kleines problem und zwar habe ich mein
handy
dahinten am laden das problem ist das
ding geht einfach nicht an
es funktioniert man guckt euch das mal
an ihr könnt ihr wahrscheinlich ähnlich
sehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin so froh dass das jetzt
wenigstens angegangen ist sie hatte
schon angst so leute ich hab das jetzt
schon laden lassen möchtest du jetzt
hier
es ist voll komisch ich denke sich ganz
immer nicht entspannen weil ich habe man
das ist schon so dumme welcher trottel
denkt sich kommen wir machen den usb
anschluss nach oben
so jetzt hab ich dann sperrt so hier ich
mache das kurz mal an und schreibt er
über dann ist es entsperrt jedes der
place to work sap ist schon download
hier kann man ins internet youtube und
so kann man alles runter laden glaube
das ding hat sogar 8 gb speicher gar
nicht mal so schlecht natürlich nicht
vergleichbar mit anderen handys aber ist
okay ich finde so als übergangs handy
kann man damit also leute ganz schnell
vielleicht um ein foto test hier ist die
kamera jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ach du
scheiße schaut euch die kamera
okay das self wie wir drehen das makro
is ok jetzt mal kurz foto von mir ja ja
so sieht das foto aus ich weiß nicht
vielleicht könnt ihr das jetzt gar nicht
mehr so genau erkennen es ist auf jeden
fall total schlechte qualität aber gut
das ist klar
man erkennt mich aber ich bin trotzdem
günstig und man kann run zoomen bevor
ich da jetzt wieder alles mögliche
analysiere ich glaube das ist ein
bisschen zeitaufwendig ist alles möglich
man kann ins internet man kann apps
tonlosen man kann youtube videos schauen
und so weiter also an sich ist es ein
handy war es jetzt natürlich nicht gut
ist aber voll okay halt für 30 euro also
es kann also es zwar nicht besonders
schnell aber funktioniert der touch
funktioniert man kann halt alles machen
was man mit einem anderen samsung handy
oder so auf machen kann
die frage ist jetzt was mache ich mit
den beiden handys was mache ich mit dem
alcatel andy was mache ich mit diesem
handy das wahrscheinlich gleich
explodiert bevor ich die jetzt einfach
hier rumliegen habe ich werde die eh
nicht benutzen das weiß ich ganz genau
ich könnte die verschenken oder so ich
kann es aber auch die immer einfach
verlosen
ich habe das andere handy jetzt gerade
bei meinen eltern das ist jetzt nicht
hier aber ich würde sagen keine ahnung
ich kann ja auch noch drauf schreiben
oder so ich weiß nicht was muss ich mir
dann sagen oder noch irgendwas
darzulegen
deswegen wenn ihr ganz eins davon hätte
kommentiert einfach mit eurem instagram
namen unter diesem video oder
kommentiert mein instagram foto mein
letztes oder so könnt ihr auch gerne
machen weil das ist einfach
übersichtlicher dann habe ich sofort
einen instagram namen kann ich sofort
kontaktieren auf instagram hat sich alex
wie lass doch nach oben da macht das
nicht nach also denkt nicht wenn ihr
jetzt auf das handy bestellt bekommt ihr
sofort 2 ich denke das war eine
einmalige sache
ich bin gespannt ob sich da noch
irgendwas meldet oder ob ich da eine
mail zu bekommen dass ich ein handy
wieder abgeben soll oder so ich denke
zwar nicht im endeffekt musste ich auch
irgendwo unterschreiben dass ich das
anderen die bekommen habt musste glaube
ich nur noch einen kleinen betrag um
draufzahlen
ja das war es mit dem video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen und wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich morgen wieder haut rein